une épée de damoclès voilà comment les
états unis voient la possible levée en
octobre de l'embargo sur les armes pour
l'iran
mike pompéo va même plus loin dans son
plaidoyer outre l'instabilité économique
du moyen-orient menacé par cette levée
le secrétaire d'état américain met en
garde l'europe
si vous n'agissez pas l'iran sera libre
d'acheter des avions de chasse de
fabrication russe capable de frapper
dans un rayon de 3000 km mettant ainsi
des villes comme ryad new delhi rome et
varsovie dans le collimateur iranien
l'iran sera libre de moderniser des
temps de sa flotte de sous marins de
manière à menacer davantage la
navigation internationale et la liberté
de navigation dans le détroit d'ormuz le
golfe persique et la mer dauman
faire pression sur l'europe c'était
l'objectif des etats-unis dans cette
vision conférence du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu
puisque pékin et moscou ont été on ne
peut plus clair sur le sujet nous ne
pouvons pas accepter de tentatives
visant à obtenir la bénédiction du
conseil de sécurité pour la politique de
pression maximale voulue par les états
unis et pour la légitimer des arguments
qui n'ont pas empêché washington de
remettre à leurs 14 partenaires du
conseil de sécurité un projet de
résolution prévoyant une extension sans
limite de l'embargo sur les armes
appliqué à l'iran une demande qui a
plongé dans l'embarras les européens
signataires du jc perreault à leur
volonté de préserver à tout prix
l'accord de vienne de 2015
en dépit des coups de boutoir des états
unis et la levée de l'embargo sur les
armes
prévu le 18 octobre dans une résolution
ayant entériné le jcp oa est une
condition du maintien de cet accord
pour rappel le comté de sécurité compte
actuellement cinq membres européens le
royaume-uni la france l'allemagne
l'estonie et la belgique
washington n'est pas sûr de disposer
d'une majorité de neuf voix en faveur de
son texte un texte que mohammad javad
zarif n'a pas hésité à dénoncer les
etats-unis leurs complices dans les
crimes de guerre au yémen sont allés
plus loin dans leur désormais triste et
célèbre campagne d'intimidation contre
les institutions internationales
plus récemment ils ont contraint le
secrétariat général de l'onu à s'appuyer
sur des allégations qui servaient leurs
propres intérêts et sur des documents
falsifiés pour produire un rapport
entièrement dépourvu de
professionnalisme et ne relevant pas du
mandat du secrétariat dont le passé les
etats-unis ont menacé si jamais
l'embargo n'étaient pas prolongées de
déclencher un processus de ré imposition
général de sanctions internationales à
l'iran
prévue par le jcp aux as problème ils ne
font plus partie de cet accord depuis
mai 2018
l'union européenne la russie la chine
qui continue d'en être membre rejette
donc ce droit d'activer ce processus si
washington ait aussi intransigeant sur
cette question c'est avant tout parce
qu'ils accusent téhéran de
vouloir se doter de l'arme atomique et
de déstabiliser le moyen-orient
notamment au yémen au liban ou en syrie
en réaction à la sortie américaine de
l'accord de vienne l'iran a annoncé en
début d'année s'affranchir de ces
limites imposées en uranium enrichi
[Musique]